[intense music]
All right, bladesmiths,
your blades have been tested.
They've been evaluated.
The judges have deliberated.
And here are the standings.
In fourth place, we've got
Gary earning one point.
In third place, Gene,
you earned three points.
And our first place
competitor is Chad.
You got 10 points, buddy.
Matt, that leaves you with six.
Everybody's done fantastic work.
And now it's time
for our second event.
All right, gentlemen, over
here on our pantry shelves,
we've got stacks of 15
and 20 and 1095 steel.
What does that mean gentlemen?
Damascus.
That's right.
This is a Damascus challenge.
And it's going to
be made even more
tough because in
our second event,
you're not making
just one blade,
you're making two
throwing knives.
Gentlemen, do your best.
Your three hours starts now.
I've never made
it throwing knife,
so today is going to be my first
and second throwing knives.
I'm taping up my ruler so I
can't screw up my parameters.
All I got to do is tape
between these two blue lines
and I'm golden.
If you start with
good steels, it
makes it a better possibility
of getting good welds.
[sizzling]
The only kind of throwing
weapon I've ever made before
was a tomahawk, and that's
not at all the same.
I designed kind
of a throwing knife.
Got a good tip on it.
But it's also going
to have a lot of meat
so that you can really feel
it when you're throwing it.
I really want to focus
on keeping it simple,
just really trying to
meet the parameters.
It's a tall order, but I
feel confident in my skills.
So I'm satisfied with
the taking of my weld.
So now it's time to
dance with Big Blue.
Me and Big Blue, we
got a relationship now.
You know, we're pretty tight.
I actually narrow it
down in the center.
And I'm going to
draw up the handles.
At this point,
everything's going great.
Couldn't be happier.
So it looks like my
billet is up to heat.
I'm going to set my
welds with a hammer.
It's a lot more
cautious approach to me
to set it by hand.
But you know, I can't be
too careful at this point.
I can really be particular on
exactly where I hit the billet
and not being too violent
by going over to Big Blue
and just smashing
the heck out of it.
I really need to get
the billet nice and hot
so that these pieces will
all forge well together.
So I don't to rush this
part of the process.
If they don't set, I'm not
going to be able to get
two knives out of the steel.
I get my steel hot and
I'm over to the press--
Oh no, these welds didn't hold.
It's kind of like if you're
making that big sandwich,
take a big bite, and everything
comes out the other damn end,
and it's all over the floor.
So now I'm looking at my
billet, it's not forge welded.
And I'm going to have to
figure this out right now.
I can't come in fourth
because that's going to put
me out of the competition.
This time, I get it really hot
and allow the width of that
die to sandwich it down.
I do feel like it's
starting to weld to itself,
which is the ultimate goal.
But it's going to have to
go right back in the heat.
I'm going to have to
repeat this process
a few times before I can
really start drawing this out.
My game plan is
try to get these two
knives as similar as possible.
Now I have two
identical throwing
knives at 12 inches long.
I realized that
they're real heavy.
I want them heavy.
You have to throw them real
hard, but man, do they stick.
And they make a
really loud thunk.
So I finally get
my steel drawn out.
Cut them in half.
I want to quench
my blades early,
so that's going to
guarantee me a hard edge.
I wouldn't call them knives yet.
They're more like bricks.
I feel good, but
I know that it's
still really anyone's game.
I make the decision
to just quench
the tip, thinking
that's the only
critical area of the blade.
I have one of my knives cooling
down, so what I need to do
is set up another vice
at another station.
So I go to the scrap pit,
and I'm going to go find two
matching pieces of angle iron.
Ow!
[bleep]
I snagged the inside
of my left arm.
I'm that guy.
I'm bleeding on
"Forged in Fire."
I'm just going to do a
little bit of an edge quench.
There's no need for
the tang or the side
of the knife to be hard.
I mean, we're throwing
these things around,
so you don't want them to break.
As I'm starting to
finish up and realizing
that they're pretty similar,
it's what I was shooting for.
But things don't always work out
when you only have three hours.
My plan is to heat treat
one knife and then the other.
I'm just going to harden maybe
the last quarter of the knife
because that's the
part that's going
to be digging into the wood.
I feel pretty good.
You know, we're
down to the wire,
so I'm going to have
to keep hustling.
But I'm going to work
till the last second.
So I've got the edges
kind of profiled in.
It's time to start
working on the handle.
But the problem is the buffing
bell took my edge with it.
Oh boy.
I don't have time to fix it.
So here I am again stuck with
some bad on-the-spot decisions.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1!
Bladesmiths, stop
what you're doing.
Shut down your machines.
Drop your tools.
[applause]
I'm frustrated,
I'm disappointed.
But I'm also relieved because
I was concerned I wasn't going
to be able to turn anything in.
All right, gentlemen,
welcome to the knife throwing
triple threat.
All right, Gene,
you're up first year.
Are you ready?
- Yes, sir.
[intense music]
[thunking]
[clanking]
All right, so Gene, right
off, a lot of weight to these.
So a fairly classic shape
overall for a thrower.
What I do appreciate is that
the handles are even in size.
The handles feel
the same regardless
of the knife, which is really
what I was looking for.
When we moved to
the harder target,
this knife did take
a bit of damage,
and you did lose just
a tip right there.
Just packed out a little bit.
But these didn't start out with
a lot of point on them, anyway.
But they threw well.
Good job.
- Thank you, sir.
- All right, Chad, you're up.
You ready for this?
- Yes, sir.
OK, let's do this.
[intense music]
[thunking]
[clanking]
All right, so Chad, I
think you nailed it.
These are a great
weight, a great size.
Feel super comfortable
in my hand.
They match really nicely.
This is something that's
super important in throwing.
Your tips, they hit
into the clay pigeons,
didn't lose any tip.
Just a great job all around.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Gary, you're up.
You ready for this?
Let's do it.
OK.
[thunking]
[shattering]
So right off, when I looked
at these, I was like, nah,
I don't like them.
[laughs] I'm proven wrong again.
[laughs] These actually
throw really good.
I did not think
this skinny dropped
handle would throw well.
It actually feels
better like that.
I was throwing them with the
curve going up into my hand
as opposed to down.
They throw really nicely.
They've got a really
sharp point on them.
When it penetrates, it just
buries itself really nicely.
The back of the handle, there's
a couple of spots on here
that I can feel.
They didn't really drag
when it left my hand.
But they threw really
well, so good job.
Thank you.
All right, Matt,
you're up next.
Are you ready to go?
Sure.
[thunking]
Nice.
[clanking]
Nice one, Matt.
Thanks, brother.
So Matt, these
things are heavy.
These have what I like
to call the brick factor.
It's like throwing a brick.
It doesn't matter if you
hit it with a point or not,
whoever you hit is going down.
The blades themselves
don't quite match.
You've got one lean blade
and one wider blade.
But what I do like is the
handles match beautifully
and they really
fit my hand well.
They do have a very
cute point in profile.
I would have loved to have
seen a little bit leaner,
but I mean, it's hard to
argue with how easy it
was to get accurate with these.
As far as being tough, your
points are still there.
Well done.
Thank you, sir.
[intense music]
All right, bladesmiths, the
second event in the Summer
Forging Games is
complete, and the judges
need to have a deliberation.
I remind you that after
this deliberation,
the person with
the lowest points
will be eliminated
from the games.
Bladesmiths, we need
the forge floor.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths, the
second event in our summer
forging games is complete.
The judges' deliberation
is complete.
And they have ranked your work.
In first place, Chad,
congratulations.
That's 10 more
points to you, buddy,
giving you a point total of 20.
In second place, Gary,
our come-from-behind guy.
you came out of that first
round with just one point
and now you've
made up another six
points, giving you seven total.
Our third place
finisher is Matt.
Congratulations.
That's three points to
you adding to your six
from the first event.
That gives you
nine points total.
And our fourth place
finisher is Gene.
You came in third
on the first event
and here coming in fourth
in the second event
gives you one point
for a total of four.
Gene, you came out with
the least number of points
after two events.
Unfortunately, at this
time, you've been eliminated
from the Summer Forging Games.
My knives performed poorly.
The other bladesmiths
did a better job,
and I'm cool with that.
Hey, it was a good fight, man.
Thank you, sir
I've learned a
lot and I'm just
excited to go back home, put
that new knowledge to work,
become a better bladesmith, and
hopefully come back one day,
and show these judges
what I'm capable of.